- My name is Chris Kraus.
I'm currently the chair of the
classics department at Yale.
That said, I'm now going to back off
and introduce you to the introducers,
the two faculty members who are organizing
the series currently,
beginning with my
beloved former colleague,
Irene Peirano Garrison,
who is currently the Pope
Professor of Latin at Harvard,
if you can believe it.
So, Irene.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
It's such a pleasure to
see the community gathered
to hear Shelley Haley today.
Thank you, Chris,
and also to my co-organizer, Ayesha,
for inviting me back for
this momentous occasion.
I want to tell you a little bit
about the background to this lecture.
It was the spring of 2018
when Ayesha and I were asked,
I believe by Emily
Greenwood at that point,
to take over the organization
of the Parry Lectures
after our colleagues, Chris
Kraus and David Quinn,
had quite a long stint in that position.
And as Ayesha and I
began plotting a strategy
and a course for the Parry Lectures,
it became immediately clear
to us that race was a topic
that was ubiquitous and
bubbling beneath the surface
in so many conversations and encounters
that we were having with
students and colleagues,
but a topic that at that point
wasn't present enough
in academic discourse
and frameworks that we were
encountering in our work
in pre-modern studies, certainly at Yale.
How to talk about race from
a historical perspective,
how to draw from critical frameworks
in ways that are sensitive
to the specificity
of the pre-modern world
and above all, a topic
that is very dear to us,
how to weave scholarly narratives
and perspectives in and out of reflections
on embodied identities
in the here and now,
these all seemed really pressing questions
to us at the time.
We were immediately drawn
to Shelley Haley's
exemplary investment in all
of these questions from angles that are
at once scholarly, deeply political,
but also deeply personal.
And you will all might
immediately recognize
in particular her trailblazing work
on Fanny Jackson Coppin and
other black women classicists
and other seminal
contributions on translation,
race and the classics that
I'm sure my colleague, Ayesha,
will mentioned momentarily.
We initially planned this
lecture for March, 2020,
but as we all know,
back then we were in the
grips of the epidemics
and we were forced to postpone.
We could not have predicted a year,
even two years ago,
that the summer of civil unrest
and awakening that we
experienced last year
after the murder of George Floyd
and that of so many
others made the questions
all the more pressing
and avoiding those questions
unconscionable, frankly.
We're grateful to Professor Haley
for accepting the original invitation
and we're so excited for the opportunity
that this unavoidable
postponement provides us
to engage with her groundbreaking work
and learn from her unique personal voice.
So thank you and onto you, Ayesha.
- Thank you, Irene,
and this is one of those
lectures where there is a chain
of introductions, which is,
is no less than what
I think Shelley Haley certainly deserves.
Before I do the the ritual
formality of introduction,
I do wanna point briefly to an extension
of what Irene began to talk about,
which is the intersection of voice,
critical subjectivity
and the nature of our scholarship.
The Parry Lecture in classics
and comparative literature speaks
to a very wide range of scholars,
those not just in classics,
but those of us who draw on
and are adjacent to
and engage variously with
the work in classics,
in comparative literature
and other literary and
humanities disciplines at large.
I wanna begin by noting that
Shelley Haley's work first came
to my attention, not for
her work as a classicist
but because I was teaching a course
in global Shakespeares
and I wanted to find an
essay that would introduce
my students to the challenges
of reading Shakespeare's Cleopatra.
And the essay that I assign regularly now
is Shelley's classic
essay from the early 90s,
"Black Feminist Thought and the Classics"
an essay that blew open
my students' minds,
not only for its careful
working through of the manner
and mode of scholarship
on a complicated subject like Cleopatra,
but also for its ownership
of her own position
as a scholarly subject,
as a student,
as a member of many complex,
overlapping communities.
And it is that voice that I
think has reached scholars
across a very wide range of disciplines
and that I certainly,
and I know many others here today,
are excited to hear.
So by way of introduction, I
would actually like to start
with some words that
Shelley herself has written
which I think are particularly crucial
for our own moment today
as we begin this Parry Lecture.
Quoting Patricia Williams,
Shelley Haley writes
in that seminal essay,
"Black Feminist Thought and the Classics"
and this is Williams,
my attempts to write in my
own voice have placed me
in the center of a
snarl of social tensions
and crossed boundaries.
And reflecting on that
quote, Shelley writes,
think of the possibilities in my case,
feminist classicist and women classicist,
black classicist and
black woman's classicist
and black feminist and
black feminist classicist.
If oxymoronic odds come in degrees,
I would be somewhere near the high end.
How did I come in this location
as a black feminist classicist?
I welcome Shelley Haley here,
both for her extraordinary career,
she is currently the president
of the Society for Classical Studies
and she is Edward North Chair of Classics
and Professor of Africana
Studies at Hamilton College.
Professor Haley earned her BA
from Syracuse University in 1972.
She received her MA in
1975 and her PhD in 1977,
both from the University of Michigan.
An expert on the figurative Cleopatra,
she has lectured widely on
increasing the representation
of students of color in Latin,
ancient Greek and classics classrooms
and on her research about the role
of a classical education in the lives
and careers of 19th century
college educated black women.
Her publications include
Fanny Jackson Coppin's
"Reminiscences of School Life,
and Hints On Teaching" 1995,
and numerous articles on the role
of women in the ancient world
and on race and the
discipline of classics.
In 2017, she received
an award for excellence
in teaching at the collegiate level
from the Society of Classical Studies.
It's with enormous admiration
and a certain amount of modeling
and exemplary awe
that I welcome Shelley Haley
to give the Parry Lecture.
Welcome, Professor Haley.
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
It's an absolute honor to be here.
I would like to start first
with a land acknowledgement.
I respectfully acknowledge
the Oneida Nation
of the Haudenosaunee,
their elders, both past and present,
as well as future generations.
This acknowledgement
demonstrates solidarity
and commitment to the
beginning of the process
of dismantling the ongoing
legacies of settler colonialism.
I'd like to thank the departments
of comparative literature and classics
for inviting me to
deliver the Parry Lecture.
I really am beyond honored to do this
and I wanna give a special
shout out to Ayesha
and Irene for persisting
with the invitation.
You both have been wonderful contacts
and great models for
how to treat guests
that you invite to give a lecture.
Before I begin,
I wonder if we could just
have a moment of silence
for the victims of gun violence,
especially Colorado
and especially the eight
victims in Georgia,
six of whom were Asian women.
Thank you.
One of the most frustrating
questions I have received
throughout my career is,
which oppression has hindered
you more in classics,
racism or sexism?
The prescient work of the
Combahee River Collective
in their statement and the advent
of critical race feminist
theory has helped me
and other black indigenous women
of color formulate
responses which deconstruct
such questions and reconstruct
the totality of our limited experiences.
One such reconstruction is the
concept of racialized gender.
In discussions about systemic oppression,
the broader framework of
racialized gender can be specified
as gendered racism
or racialized sexism.
But today I will be working
within the broader concept
of racialized gender when
discussing ancient Hellenic
and Roman societies.
Our reception of race and gender
in the ancient world is
situated within the frameworks
we employ, knowingly or unknowingly,
to analyze these societies.
In recent years, feminist scholars
and scholars of race studies
have abandoned the approaches
of positivism and turned to
those of social construction
and intersectionality.
The term intersectionality was coined
by the legal scholar, Kimberle Crenshaw,
in her 1989 article "The
Marginalizing the Intersection
of Race and Gender: A
Black Feminist Critique
of Antidiscrimination
Doctrine, Feminist Theory
and Antiracist Politics."
I love that title because
it's so Victorian.
You know how Victorians
give really long titles.
Anyway.
However, as a concept,
it is rooted in the earlier
1977 Combahee River Collective
statement authored by Barbara Smith,
Beverly Smith and Demita Frazier.
The statement was one of
the clearest articulations
of the simultaneity of
oppressions that women
of African descent, in particular, suffer.
Since Crenshaw's articulation,
intersectionality has
spread as an analytical tool
beyond disciplines and borders.
Intersectional projects and
methods exist in a wide range
of fields from its original jurisprudence,
sociology and education,
to history, psychology and even business
Very few theories have generated the kind
of interdisciplinary and global engagement
that marks the intellectual
history of intersectionality.
Yes, okay.
Intersectionality is a
critical intervention
against the acentralism
of critical race theory
and is a core concept of
critical race feminism,
hereafter CRF.
The anti-acentralism of CRF has,
according to one scholar,
quote, provided a critique
of the feminist notion
that there is an essential female voice
that is that all women feel
one way on the subject.
CRF highlights the
situation of women of color
whose lives may not conform to
an essential norm, end quote.
Increasingly, scholars of
the ancient world are finding
intersectionality a useful tool
to examine ancient societies
but in a limited way.
Often classicists neglect
the core axis of race
in their application of the concept.
For some time now, the concept
of social construction has proved fruitful
in the efforts to uncover
the social constructions
of race and gender which
operated in ancient societies.
Adrien Katherine Wing notes
that social constructions
thesis helps us realize that,
quote, biological races do not exist,
as recent science has clearly shown.
There is more genetic difference
within so-called races than between them.
Instead, races have been
socially constructed
and the legal system
reifies that construction,
privileging some races
over others, end quote.
The same analysis applies to genders
and the intersection of race and gender.
A sterling example of the
social construction of race
in the United States comes
to us from Ta-Nehisi Coates
and I quote, but race is the
child of racism, not the father
and the process of naming the
people has never been a matter
of genealogy and physiognomy
as much as one of hierarchy.
This difference in hue and hair is old,
but the belief in the
preeminence of hue and hair,
the belief that these factors
can correctly organize
a society and that they
signify deeper attributes,
which are indelible,
this is the new idea at the heart
of these new people who have
been brought up hopelessly,
tragically to believe that they are white,
end quote.
While both these modern
approaches can get us closer
to understanding what Tim
Whitmarsh has described
as hybridized ancient
Greek and Roman worlds,
they still are flawed
by exclusive binaries
that is either/or inherited
by Western epistemological frameworks
and arguably first expressed by Aristotle.
For race, recasting Whitmarsh's concept of
hybridization
as creolization is a first step
in dismantling these binaries.
Furthermore, such reframing
aids in breaking down
the influence of modern social
constructs of race and gender
which undergirds our
reception and perception
of race and gender in antiquity.
For gender, the construct goes back
to the 19th century when the
rise of eugenic movements
and the cult of true
womanhood were the scaffolding
upon which the gender construct was based.
The concept of racialized
gender provides, I think,
a fruitful way of
discussing the intersection
of race and gender in antiquity.
Up to now, it has been Marxist feminists
who have applied the
concept to labor movements
and labor history where
the intersection of race,
gender and class has been
paramount to the discussion.
However, the broader parameters
of the concept can apply
trans-historically to antiquity.
As Eileen Boris states, quote,
race and gender exist in tandem
to transform profoundly the
ways that each works alone.
Constructed through
gendered representations,
race, in turn, reconstructs
gender identities.
The concept of racialized
gender reflects the interaction.
Furthermore, Boris shows
that racialized gender aids
in dismantling the simplistic binary
that men have race,
women have a gender,
end quote.
So, how would this very
modern concept work
when applied retrospectively
to ancient Hellenic
and Roman societies?
Let's go on a journey
and examine three case
studies, so to speak,
Medea,
Cleopatra
and Sophonisba.
This entails taking a broad view
of race to break out of
the traditional binaries
and coded language that is using
ethnicity in place of race.
In these case studies I try
to stress that the perception
and reception of women
and men is influenced
by racialized gender.
I hope to show that the
intersection of race
and gender in antiquity reflects
the transformational nature
of racialized gender that Boris described
in the quote above.
Before discussing the
details of the intersection
of race and gender in the ancient world,
it is important to set out
the operating principles
of the discussion.
First and foremost, social constructs
of race and gender existed in antiquity
but
they were not the same as modern times
but nevertheless, they existed.
However, it cannot be stressed enough
that the reception of the
ancient constructs of race
and gender in later times
is profoundly influenced
by the hierarchical framing
described by Coates and others.
Pushing against that framing to arrive
at a more plausible analysis of race
and gender in antiquity
is the intellectual
and moral imperative of this lecture.
Ancient formulations of race and gender,
like their modern counterparts,
were not static, nor were they immutable.
Jonathan Hall notes this in his work on
what he calls ethnic groups,
I would call them races but
he calls them ethnic groups,
in Hellenic society.
Quote, ethnic groups are
not static or monolithic,
but dynamic and fluid.
Their boundaries are permeable to a degree
and they may be subject to
processes of assimilation
and differentiation, end quote.
While we can argue that
there were relatively uniform
Roman constructs of race and gender,
we cannot say that there
were monolithic constructs
in ancient Hellenic societies.
These were tied closely to
various demographic groups
in different city states
around the Aegean.
So as far as possible,
I'm going to refer to the city states by
name.
The Hellenic peoples enshrined
different racial categories
in their mythic foundations.
In this regard, the narratives concerning
racial genealogies are forms
of social construction,
as ancient societies strived
to explain the racial
differences through a shared ancestry.
In the myths surrounding the
genesis of Hellenic peoples,
the ancestors of the three
major racial groups are depicted
as descendants of Zeus or Helen.
Aeolus,
Doris
and Ion
became the [Indistinct] founders
of the Aeolian, Dorian and Ionian races.
Each race also shared
linguistic and cultural traits.
It is in the latter sphere
that the intersection of race
and gender is clear.
The Ionian people, best
represented by Athens,
constructed gender and gender
relations along rigid lines,
especially after the legislation of Solon
in the sixth century BCE.
Given the importance of racialized gender
for the construction of the
identity for Hellenic peoples,
it is not surprising
to find it illustrated
in cultural production,
especially literature.
This brings us to Medea,
a mythic character
who has become epitome
of a racialized gender.
She is best known to us from
Euripides' tragedy, "Medea"
and nearly all the receptions of that play
from Seneca to Toni Morrison focus
on the trope of the mother
who kills her own children.
But what did Euripides know?
He undoubtedly knew Medea as the daughter
of Aeetes of Colchiss,
as the niece of Circe
and so the granddaughter of Helios.
He was familiar with the
Corinthiaca, now lost,
an epic poem which described the death
of Medea's children in the Temple of Hera.
Other versions of the story
portray the Corinthians
as the murderers of the children.
As retribution, the
Corinthians were forced
to establish a hero cult for the children.
In the fifth century BCE,
the stain of infanticide
still haunted the Corinthians
and so they commissioned
Euripides to revision the myth.
In Euripides' hands,
Medea becomes the foreign
woman extraordinaire,
yet the description of Medea as foreign
had a way of masking
her racialized gender.
So beyond divine genealogy,
how did Euripides read
Medea's racial ancestry?
Herodotus informs us that
Colchis was colonized
by the Egyptian pharaoh, Sesostris,
probably Sesostris II.
Herodotus states and I quote,
the Egyptians did, however,
say that they thought the
original Colchians were men
from Sesostris's army.
My own idea on the subject was based first
on the fact that they had
black skins and wooly hair,
not that amounts to much as
other nations have the same.
And secondly, and more especially,
on the fact that the Colchians,
the Egyptians and the
Ethiopians are the only races
which from ancient times
practiced circumcision,
end quote.
Now this information
from Herodotus comes in,
within the context of the
construction of peoples
other than Hellenic as a barbarian,
that's Herodotus' word.
With this knowledge in hand,
Euripides then establishes
Medea as racially
and culturally other
and sets her up as a foil to
Jason's racialized gender,
one that is constructed as more civilized
and hence superior.
Euripides' revision has
had such sustaining power
because it resonated
with later internalized
negative perceptions of
the racialized gender,
particularly of women of African descent.
In Jason's soliloquy,
after the infanticide,
he declares that, quote,
no woman born in a Hellenic society would
ever have gone through with such a crime.
And later in the same passage,
he invokes animal and monster imagery.
A lioness, not a woman, you.
More cruel in nature
than the Etruscan Scylla.
Flash forward to the 19th
through 21st centuries,
we black women have been masculinized,
declared unfit mothers
and portrayed as not just angry,
but full of rage.
Yet what gets largely ignored
is that Jason cannot succeed
without Medea's knowledge and skills.
And even after the murder of her children,
she, not the Corinthians,
buries her children
and establishes a cult in their honor.
It is notable that in Euripides' "Medea"
it is the chorus of Corinthian women
who express the injustice
of women's position
in Euripides' Athens.
These female members of the
Aeolian demographic demonstrate
a different construction of gender
when they reflect on the
historical treatment of women.
It is to the thoughts of
men which are deceitful,
their pledges which are loose.
The stories of women shall
not turn our condition
into a fair one
so that our lives shall
achieve proper glory.
New value is coming for female kind,
no longer shall slanders
pollute our story.
The poems of long ago bards
shall no more portray us
as fickle, untrustworthy friends,
biased because Apollo
forbore to implant his lyrics
in feminine minds.
I tried to do that as a
rap, but it wasn't working,
so, my apologies.
Despite this plea for
equality of representation
in literature and history,
the "Medea", the play,
concretizes the binary
between foreign born
and native women in the
Hellenic male consciousness.
Now before discussing racialized gender
as constructed by the Romans,
we need to establish the gender norm.
Just as in the United States,
when we say African American
men, we mean black men.
I'm sorry, when we say African
Americans, we men black men.
And when we say Americans,
we mean white men.
So for the Romans, Romani meant Roman men
and Roman masculinity racialized gender
in and of itself was the norm in the texts
of Roman literature.
Roman society was
patriarchal and endocentric.
The authorship of the texts we'll look at,
being all male, reflects that.
Gender difference is
filtered through a male lens
and that lens is the framework
for gender difference.
It's like a circular argument.
Racialized gender was central
to the founding of Rome
from whatever starting .1 case,
whether the legends of Aeneas or those
of his descendants, Romulus and Remus,
the intersection of race and
gender formed the foundation
of Rome's origins.
But Julio-Claudians, the founding dynasty
of the Roman Empire,
claimed ancestry of the god, Venus.
Furthermore, the Romans
constructed a national identity
upon the Trojan hero, Aeneas.
As a son of Venus,
he imparted to the Romans a
shared ancestry with Venus.
Any discussion of racialized gender
as it appears in the literary production
of the Augustan Age would be remiss
without explicit attention paid
to Cleopatra VII of Egypt.
Cleopatra was the inspiration
for Virgil's reception
of Dido in the Aeneid
and as we will see for Livy's retelling
of the story of Sophonisba.
The intersection of Cleopatra's race
and gender was paramount to the treatment
that the historical Cleopatra received
from prominent Romans,
such as Cicero and Augustus, as Octavian.
Consequently, it should be no surprise
that this intersection weighed heavily
on the literary imagination of the writers
of the Augustan period.
After all, Cleopatra embodies
the racialized gender
which pervades all the fears
of the Roman ruling class men,
a foreign woman with political
power in a geopolitical area
which historically produced
Rome's most tenacious
and feared rivals, Hannibal and Cleopatra.
So, how does Cleopatra
fare in the Rome, Roman
and Rome-identified authors who
dominate the source material
and who would write their accounts one
to two centuries after she died?
Let's look at the two major ones,
Plutarch and Cassius Dio,
both of whom wrote their works in Greek
and both of whom embed their discussions
of Cleopatra within the
life stories of men.
Plutarch especially capitalizes
on Cleopatra's racialized
gender to draw fortuitive Cleopatra
as a highly educated,
wily seductress
who becomes the ultimate femme fatale
for the Roman men she encounters.
He never gives Cleopatra an
explicit physical description,
relying instead on intangible qualities
such as the timbre of her voice.
These intangibles come
across as enchanting
and her ability of molding
her personality to her prey
conjures up the shape shifters
and tricksters of mythology.
Nothing in Plutarch's description leads us
to believe Cleopatra was
or is worthy of our trust,
nor was she worthy of the Romans.
He highlights Cleopatra's
racialized gender
by comparing her to the
ideal representative
of Roman racialized gender, Octavia.
Again, there is a no
explicit physical description
for Octavia, the sister Octavian,
who would later be called
Augustus, that you all know,
after Cleopatra committed suicide.
What does Plutarch say about Octavia?
Now, I have things
bolded in my script here,
so I'm gonna try that like
emphasize with my voice
so you know what I have bolded.
All right.
Octavian, this is Plutarch,
Octavian was very fond of
his sister who, it is said,
he doesn't know, right?
Just to be clear, he doesn't know, okay.
Who, it is said,
was a marvel of a woman.
She was a widow, having been married
to Gaius Marcellus who had recently died.
Antony too, was considered a widower
now that Fulvia had died.
He, that is Anthony, did
not deny his involvement
with Cleopatra but did
not call it marriage.
Though he still wrestled against,
wrestled against,
his love for the Egyptian woman.
Everyone supported this
marriage to Octavia
in hopes that she,
since she had dignity
and intelligence
in addition to considerable beauty,
might support and be loved by Anthony
as was fitting for such a woman
and that she would represent the salvation
and harmony of all their affairs.
In 35, that's the end of Plutarch,
in 35 BCE,
Octavia arrived in the East with supplies
for Anthony's war against Parthia
and according to many historians,
Octavian agreed to this trip in the hopes
that Anthony would disrespect
his sister by staying
with Cleopatra in Egypt,
instead of going to Athens and Octavia,
according to Plutarch.
Upon her arrival in Athens,
Octavia received a letter from Anthony
who ordered her to remain there.
But she,
though she was upset
and saw through Anthony's pretext,
nevertheless wrote to inquire
where he would like her
to send the things she was bringing him.
And a friend of Antony was sent
to deliver this message to him
and he, the friend, brought
along with it justified
and appropriate praises
of her, that is Octavia.
Cleopatra perceived
that Octavian was advancing on her
and feared that if Octavia
added to her decorum
and Caesar's power,
the pleasure of her company
and her support of Anthony,
she would be untouchable
and would have total
command of her husband.
So Cleopatra feigned
passionate love for Anthony
and made her whole body waste
away with a strict diet.
That's the end of Plutarch.
Plutarch mentions how
Cleopatra employed lobbyists,
that's my word,
with Anthony to scold him
and call him out for being, quote,
for being a, quote,
harsh, unfeeling destroyer
of a woman who was depending
on him and him alone,
end quote.
They declared that Octavia had a brother
and, quote, enjoyed the
name of wife, end quote.
But poor Cleopatra, who ruled over many,
had to be content with
being called, quote,
Anthony's mistress,
and she did not avoid the
term or think it beneath her,
provided that she could
see him and live with him,
end quote.
And it worked.
Anthony was persuaded that
Cleopatra might harm herself
and he, delaying his journey to Parthia,
returned to Alexandria.
Octavia returned to Rome
where according to Plutarch,
quote, she seemed to Octavian
to have been mistreated
and he ordered her to
leave Anthony, end quote.
In keeping with her ideal status,
she refused to leave her husband's house.
We all know the story, right?
She stayed and she raised all those kids.
There were like eight of them.
I mean, come on, lady,
you're nuts.
But anyway.
She refused to leave her husband's house
and begged her brother, quote,
to discount some things that had happened
to her since it would be intolerable
if the two most powerful rulers sent
the Roman people to war,
one, for the love of a woman
and the other, to avenge a relative,
end quote.
I don't think I would
have liked Octavia myself,
but that's okay.
At least based on Plutarch here.
She remained true and loyal to her word
and carried on activism
on behalf of Anthony.
Plutarch concludes the episode
and I quote, in this way she
inadvertently harmed Anthony
as he was hated for wronging
such a woman,
end quote.
Cassius Dio, writing around
202 of the common era,
composes a fictitious speech for Octavian
to adhort troops to war and
to justify his declaration
of war on Cleopatra.
In it, there are all sorts of dog whistles
for racialized gender.
Dio has his Octavian
draw upon Roman history
and Roman military pride
with statements such as,
indeed, for us as Romans,
rulers of the largest and
best part of the world
to be disparaged and downtrodden
by an Egyptian woman is
unworthy of our fathers.
Yeah, okay.
And then he goes on to list
all the great Roman victories of the past.
Dio's Octavian continues
this exhortative invective,
quote,
who would not lament to
hear that Roman knights
and senators fawn over
Cleopatra like eunuchs?
Who would not moan to hear
and see Anthony himself,
twice a council and
many times a commander,
who would not weep to see
that he has now left behind
his ancestral customs,
that he has imitated the
foreign and barbaric ones,
that he does not respect the laws
and gods of his ancestors,
but bows before that
woman like Isis or Salene,
names her children Helios and Salene
and finally calls himself
Osiris and Dionysus.
Uh!
Oh!
Octavian continues the diatribe,
saying that at first he
was sympathetic to Anthony,
even married his sister to him
and that, quote, I did not
wish to go to war with him
because he insulted my sister
or because he did not care for
the children he had with her,
or because he honored the
Egyptian woman instead of her.
No, I considered the first reason to be
that the same approach should not be taken
with both Cleopatra and Anthony
for she was clearly an enemy
because of what she did
and also because she was a foreigner.
But he, as a citizen, might
possibly be reasoned with,
end quote.
Octavian goes on to say
that Anthony's rejection
of Octavian's favors
proves that he is, quote,
either irrational or insane
for I have heard this
and believe he is under
that abominable woman's spell.
And Octavian blames Anthony
for bringing another war
to the premise,
quote, since he is enslaved to that woman.
Octavian isn't finished,
therefore let no one consider him a Roman
but rather an Egyptian.
Let no one call him Anthony,
but rather Serepion.
It's not possible for someone
living in royal luxury
and being treated like a woman
to think and act
like a man.
So, in a nutshell,
Cleopatra signifies a bad woman.
She is dehumanized
and so she can become the
scapegoat for Octavian's war.
Once Octavian becomes
princeps and Augustus
it would appear that whenever
a Roman author wanted
or needed a negative
examplum for womankind,
up pops a Cleopatra-esque character.
For Virgil, it's Dido.
For Livy, it's Sophonisba,
the daughter of a Carthaginian
noble, Hasdrubal Gisgo.
In the genre of historiography,
there's one episode in Livy's narration
of the Second Carthaginian War
that lends itself to the analysis of,
through racialized gender
and offers insight into
the racial ruptures
of Roman history.
Livy's tragedy, so to speak,
of Sophonisba delineates
the racialized gender
not only of Roman men
but also that of men and
women of African descent.
Further, the character
of Sophonisba can be seen
as the crucible for
the formation of racial
and gender identities for the Roman men,
sorry, for the Roman male
elite in the age of Augustus,
therefore Roman racial formation
and racialized gender
formation are constructed
on the bodies of two exotic others,
Sophonisba and Masinissa.
The result then is a social reproduction
of ideal Roman masculinity
through the transformation
of Masinissa's racialized gender,
from that of a Numidian
to that of a Roman.
However, none of this is
possible without Sophonisba,
who undertakes an equally
transformative racial
and gender performance,
moving from a Cleopatra-esque figure
to a Lucretia-esque one.
That is from African to Roman,
mirroring as well as
enabling the performances
of a Masinissa.
I'm gonna do my best to give
you a summary of the story
but it's a bit twisted
and so bear with me.
If you wanna make a little chart
of all the main characters,
you can do that,
but it gets a little involved.
All right.
So the prominent sources
for Sophonisba are Polybius,
who never names her
and Livy, who gives the
most fulsome account.
Okay, so Sophonisba was the daughter
of the Carthaginian leader,
Hasdrubal, the son of Gisgo,
to distinguish from Hasdrubal Barca,
the brother of Hannibal.
In a cultural tradition very familiar,
no doubt to the Romans,
Sophonisba was betrothed to Masinissa.
Okay, Sophonisba was
betrothed to Masinissa
who was the son of the leader
of the Eastern Numidians.
Okay, so Numidia is gonna be
divided into two kingdoms,
there's the East and the West.
Right, so she's engaged to Masinissa
as a way to cement a diplomatic alliance
between the Eastern
Numidians and Carthage.
But before they can wed,
a series of broken alliances
and political crises ensue.
Syphax, the leader of the Western,
right, Numidians,
and an ally of Rome,
was able to conquer Eastern Numidia.
And at that point,
Masinissa switched his
alliance to Rome, okay.
Hasdrubal now needs a Numidian alliance
and so he marries Sophonisba to Syphax,
the king of Western Numidia,
forcing Syphax to break
his alliance with Rome.
So Masinissa goes to Rome,
Syphax leaves Rome, goes to Carthage,
that's the alliance picture in a nutshell.
When the Romans invaded
Africa under the command
of Scipio and Laelius,
they with the help of
Masinissa were able then truly
to defeat Syphax and Hasdrubal.
After Masinissa captured Cirta,
Syphax's capital,
he impulsively married Sophonisba
to prevent her from
falling into Roman hands.
When,
the property of Rome,
Masinissa sent poison to his wife.
In heroic fashion, she drank it and died.
Now you probably
realize this already
but the story is much more complex
and nuanced than even
that kind of complicated
summary can relate.
For instance, each of the two
significant ancient sources
for the story of Sophonisba
relies on racialized gender,
gender stereotypes in the characterization
of Sophonisba, Masinissa and Syphax.
For instance, Polybius relates
that Scipio found it likely
that Syphax was bored by his young bride,
who he never names,
and hence by his alliance
with the Carthaginians.
The reason Polybius attributes to Scipio
for thinking this is
what's important here.
For Polybius says it was
because, and this is a quote,
of the natural fickleness of the Numidians
and their perfidy towards gods and men.
Polybius does give a hint
of Sophonisba's charming
and persuasive personality.
In this section, Sophonisba is begging
Syphax not to desert the Carthaginians
and she is moved by his injuries.
Livy is the source who spends
the most time on Sophonisba.
We learn from him that
Sophonisba was a maid
of marriageable age
and Livy describes how
Hasdrubal took advantage
of her beauty and charm
and of Syphax's passion
to bind the Numidian leader more closely
to the Carthaginian cause.
Livy's portrayal of Sophonisba
is taken up when, again,
when Masinissa captures Cirta.
Masinissa is spotted by Sophonisba,
now named by Livy,
who begs the Numidian leader
to save her from the Romans.
In the act of naming her,
Livy give Sophonisba not only agency,
but also accountability.
She is no longer the
dutiful, nubilous virgo,
doing her father's bidding.
She now has the potential
to act in her own name
and on her own behalf.
Captivated, Masinissa agrees to help her
and impetuously marries her.
None of this is pleasing for Scipio
who pedantically demonstrates to Masinissa
that Sophonisba is the property of Rome
and he must turn her over to him.
Masinissa, like the good student
of Roman ideals that he is,
goes off to consider the
advice and admonition of Scipio
and resolves to send
Sophonisba a cup of poison
which she bravely accepts.
All of the later sources give notice
of Sophonisba's beauty and education,
noting that she was well
versed in grammar and music.
These authors go on to
say that she was clever,
ingratiating and altogether so charming
that the mere sight of her
or the sound of her voice,
who does that sound like?
Sufficed to vanquish everyone,
even the most indifferent.
These later sources,
no doubt because of their distance
from the events of the
late Roman Republic,
make the conflation with
Cleopatra more explicit
than Livy needs to.
Nevertheless, the similarity
between Sophonisba's
and Cleopatra's racialized
gender is particularly striking.
Whereas the later sources seem
to be telling a touching story,
Livy's agenda is very different,
reestablishing the Roman
moral fabric of old,
one which has become badly frayed.
His main vehicle for this
is racialized gender.
As a result, each of
the male characters has
his own political and or
moral crisis occurring
and each crisis gets resolved
by reasserting the
normative racialized gender.
For instance, earlier in book 29,
Livy describes Scipio's crisis surrounding
the subjugated city of
Locri in Magna Graecia.
There had been a senatorial investigation,
it kinda sounds like today,
you know, every time something goes wrong,
there's a senatorial investigation,
into the complaints of the Locrians
and Scipio's role in them.
Livy recounts the following charges,
revealed during the
Senate's deliberations.
Much was also said against the
commander in chief himself,
this is Scipio.
His dress and bearing were unRoman,
if not and not even soldierly.
He strolled about the gymnasium
in a Greek mantle and sandals
and wasted his time over, on my God, books
and physical exercise.
Sorry for the editorial insert there.
The discipline of the whole
army had gone to the dogs,
so that it was more of
a menace to its friends
than its enemies.
Now while many or even most
of these charges were untrue,
Scipio does have an image problem
and he must reclaim
both his moral position
as the exemplar of the ideal Roman,
of ideal Roman masculinity,
as well as his political reputation
as a military commander.
Masinissa and Sophonisba
are the tools to his success
in this reclaiming.
When Masinissa conquers Cirta
and defeats Syphax,
he is an ally of Scipio
and becomes his proxy
in terms not only in military success
but also Roman racialized gender.
However, livy makes very clear
that Masinissa is racially different
to the Romans he is emulating.
Sophonisba is a vehicle
through which Livy reminds us
that our Numidian hero
is a non-Roman hero.
The beautiful Carthaginian
women will seduce him
and cause him to slip back
into his natural racialized gender
and stereotype of the Numidian.
Let's look at what happens.
When Livy first mentions Sophonisba.
it is clear that Hasdrubal, her father,
is the architect of the scheme
to win over Syphax from the Romans.
Sophonisba is a pawn in a political move.
Hasdrubal is relying on
his daughter's beauty
and Syphax's passionate nature.
However, what Sophonisba is
the agent of her own destiny
and comes out to greet Masinissa,
Livy gives her a speech that demonstrates
that she has the,
sorry,
persuasive power to
obtain whatever she wants,
as well as the racial rupture caused
by the Roman invasion of Africa.
This is Sophonisba according to Livy,
if I had been nothing other
than the wife of Syphax,
I would have preferred to trust the honor
of a Numidian and one born like me
in the same Africa
than that of an alien, an outsider.
What a daughter of Carthage,
not to mention a daughter of Hasdrubal,
has to fear from a Roman,
you do understand.
If you are able of nothing else,
then I beg and beseech you
to save me through death
from the Romans' will.
Livy overshadows Sophonisba's appeal
to Masinissa's race
loyalty by again repeating
the racial.
As he, Livy, relates the scene
after Sophonisba's speech,
he describes her as, quote,
outstanding in beauty
and at a blooming age.
From Livy's perspective,
Masinissa heard Sophonisba's speech
more as blandishments of a lover
rather than entreaties of a suppliant
because he is a Numidian
and the race of Numidians
is inclined towards passion.
That is a quote from Livy.
As a consequence, Livy says,
quote, the victor is captured
by the love for the captive.
The subsequent marriage between Sophonisba
and Masinissa also gives Livy the context
in which to contrast the
recklessness of Masinissa
and the self control of Scipio.
Livy focuses on Scipio showing
his controlled handling
of Syphax's defection,
as well as his disappointment
and even anger
over Massinissa's yielding
to his baser instincts.
When responding to why he turned
from his alliance with Rome,
Syphax places the blame
on his having wedded a Carthaginian woman.
It was madness, bred from passion.
More worrisome to Scipio,
but consistent with Liny's view
that lack of restraint has
unfortunate consequences,
is Syphax's observation that Masinissa was
neither more prudent
nor restrained than he.
In fact, Masinissa is less
cautious because of his youth.
Massinissa's hasty, impulsive
marriage to Sophonisba
supports Syphax's image of Masinissa
and provides the most telling evidence
to support Scorpio's growing anxiety.
Scipio sees clearly the
possibility that Masinissa,
although he's been very
loyal up to this point,
might now turn to the Carthaginian cause
due to the influence of Sophonisba.
In addition to his anxiety,
Scipio is disgusted,
disgusted because following mos maiorum,
he practiced self-control
and resisted the
beautiful female prisoners
when he was in Spain.
When Masinissa arrives,
Scipio receives him warmly
and lavishes public praise on him
for his military accomplishments.
There follows, however,
a private
tongue lashing.
This is Scipio,
but of these virtues
for which I would seem
to have been sought out by you,
I should've been prouder of
none as much as my self control
and my resistance to bodily lust.
How I wish that you had added this also
to your other outstanding
virtues, Masinissa.
There is not, absolutely not, believe me
as much danger to men of our age
from armed enemies as
from the constant presence
of sensuality all around us.
The man who reigns these in
and tames them with his
own self-control has earned
for himself more honor
and a greater victory
than we have with the conquest of Syphax.
Oh my goodness,
he's a self-righteous
little something, ain't he?
All right.
Livy demonstrates that Masinissa,
passionate Numidian though he may be,
is really more Roman than the Romans
and shares many of their ancient values.
However, Masinissa,
like Livy's contemporary Romans,
has lost sight of these virtues.
Scipio's exhortation to Masinissa,
not to destroy the many good qualities
with the one defective
passion could well be
Livy's words to his fellow Romans.
Masinissa fully grasped the
logic of Scipio's speech
and like many colonized people,
is caught between two worlds.
Does he abandon the colonizer
and lose all the political
advantages that might flow
from that alliance?
Or does he become a race traitor
and turn over the woman he loves to Rome?
After privately venting his grief,
he hits a kind of compromise of sorts
and provide Sophonisba
with the opportunity
to commit suicide.
When she accepts the cup of poison,
she reverts back to her
previous gender performance
of the obedient woman.
By moving from a passive,
silent and obedient daughter
to a forthright vocal
agent of her own sexual
and political destiny,
she violates the norm of Roman femininity
and becomes a Cleopatra-esque exemplar
of a corrupting foreign beauty.
When she accepts the poison,
she moves back to the obedient,
although certainly not
passive or silent wife
and restores order to the Roman male
view of gender norms in the time of Livy.
The speech that livy gives Sophonisba
as she receives the poison
places her in the tradition of Lucretia,
the noble Roman woman who
commits suicide for honor.
And I quote, I received this wedding gift,
one not unwelcome,
if a husband is able to offer
his wife nothing greater.
But tell him this, I would
have died a happier death
if I had not wed on the day of my funeral.
For this she earns
praise from Livy, quote,
she spoke calmly as she drained
fearlessly the received cup
with absolutely no indication
of trepidation, end quote.
Even though Scipio loses a trophy
to be paraded in his triumph,
who does that sound like?
He gained so much more
because of Sophonisba.
His crisis of masculinity is resolved
by the assimilation of an African man
who becomes a shining example
of Roman racialized gender
and by the suicide of an African woman
whose beauty might have dismantled
the Roman imperial agenda.
I hope I have shown that the intersection
of race and gender succinctly
expressed in the concept
of racialized gender is a useful tool
in analyzing the ancient societies
of Hellenic and Roman peoples.
Donna Haraway makes the argument that,
quote, neither gender nor race
is something with an origin
or example in the family
that then travels out into
the rest of the social world.
Rather, gender and race
are built into practice,
end quote.
This is as true in
antiquity as it is today.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you so much, Shelley,
for that wonderful detailed talk
and all those great quotations.
We will take questions,
Professor Haley will take questions now.
I would invite everyone
to either put their name
in the chat so I can see you
and call on you since there
are many people on this call
or to simply put their
question directly into the chat
and I will relay, I will read
and relay questions to Professor Haley
just to make this smoother.
So, Shelley, there are
already a few questions
and I'm gonna just go
through them one by one.
So the first question
you have is about the,
what happens to the biracial children
of Medea and Cleopatra?
And the question Lora
Holland Goldthwaite notes
that both sets of children are killed
and she asks, have you
noted instances of this kind
of hybridization being
considered monstrous somehow
and therefore such
offspring simply had to die?
- Hmm, okay.
To the second question
about monstrosity, right?
Yes and no.
Who was also biracial.
He had to die, right?
But that was a political calculation,
that wasn't based on the fact
that he was biracial, right?
The children of,
the twins, for example,
Alexander Helios and Cleopatra Selene,
seem to have had very happy lives
after the death of their parents.
It always amazes me that
that's how it's described by
folks,
after all, they were
raised by Octavia, right?
She reared them.
We know that Cleopatra Selene went on
to become a ruler in her own right
with Juba II.
And so,
from all accounts,
Alexander was,
as far as we can tell,
certainly he adjusted better
than let's say Caligula or Nero.
So he,
he seemed to have, you know, a fine life.
So I don't believe,
I mean, I've never read
any negative descriptions
of biracial children
in the sources.
So,
yeah,
and I think it's because we're,
we're sort of dealing with the
same class of people, right,
where it's not like they're
different class statuses here,
so,
yeah.
- Thanks, Suzanne Li has a question.
Suzanne, would you like
to unmute yourself?
- Hi, can you hear me?
- [Shelley and Ayesha] Yes.
- Fantastic.
Thank you so much.
It's great to be here with everybody
and with you, Shelley.
And I know we've talked about
this a little bit before
'cause, you know,
I've always,
and so in the context of,
I've always thought of
like race and gender is
like sliding scales that intersect,
we've talked about that before.
And my question for you,
like as I was listening to your talk,
was that, you know,
it seems like foreignness,
or using that word foreignness,
which seems to keep coming up,
already implies female gender in it.
So even when it's used to
describe a man it's, you know,
whether man or woman, right,
it implies a single gender,
but it doesn't seem to
work in the other way.
Like, so describing a woman,
that doesn't necessarily seem to,
or does it?
That's the question, I guess.
It doesn't seem to, like,
it seems like one is more
distinctly pointing, you know,
towards the two,
whereas if you say,
like if you look at a woman,
a Greek woman or a Roman woman
and just describe her as a woman,
does that imply for foreignness to it?
- Hmm,
that's a really, really great question
and the first thing that
springs in my mind is,
and I think it kind of
supports your point that
feminacy is implied in foreignness, right?
And that's when,
when Iarbas is praying to his father,
Jupiter Hammon,
to
put an end to this affair
between Dido and Aeneas,
the way that he describes Aeneas, right,
the description that he gives,
he calls him a semi weir, right?
He calls him the semi weir
and his hair is dripping
with perfumed oils.
Excuse me.
So everything is pointing to the fact
that he is not a man, right?
And the same with that invective
that Cassius Dio makes up
about Octavion, right?
He says, you know,
anyone who is
treated or lives the life like
of luxury like a woman
shouldn't be called a man.
So yes,
I think it's true that it's another,
it's another way to be misogynistic,
right?
But I still think that,
yeah,
it definitely,
the women get the,
the shorter end of things.
You rarely
see women.
Well, except in myth, right,
when women are masculinized,
then they sort of become monsters, right?
- Yeah, I was gonna ask.
There seems to be a monster
scale somewhere on here as well-
- Yeah, yeah, that's right.
That's right.
- Dr. Murray has talked
a bit about it too.
- Right, right.
So, yeah.
I mean, racialized gender,
at least,
modern way.
I mean, I always try to hope
that things are a bit
better in the ancient world,
but that's not always the case.
But certainly racialized gender is meant
to describe a kind of oppression
and so
it is true that women
are,
it's not a positive, right?
The outcome of it is never positive.
And I think that's probably
also true in antiquity,
especially if the woman is also foreign.
I mean, it would be
interesting to look at,
well, let's say Fulvia, right?
Fulvia violates every,
whatever,
bullet point you want in
terms of Roman femininity.
Fulvia violates those, right?
And so she gets described,
you know,
I mean she is masculinized, right,
based on her actions,
the fact that she leads
an army and she, right?
And what is it Plutarch says,
at one point he says,
Cleopatra should thank Fulvia for
training
Anthony
to yield to the control of a woman
or something.
So it's, yeah.
Yeah.
But that's a really,
I'm gonna have to think about that,
that point, that it's a
really interesting one
that it's still,
womanhood isn't raised up
because of racialized gender,
it's still considered
kind of the lower end of things, right?
Yeah.
- Thank you, Shelley.
So here's another question from the chat
and I think this is a question
that you've certainly thought more about
and alluded to early on in your talk.
But the questioner asks you
to reflect further on the
difference between ethnicity
and race and suggests
that Greek was perhaps
a linguistic category
and he writes a lot of
literature written in Greek
after Alexander was written by people
who were not born or raised Greek
and that barbarians, opposite of Greeks,
were people who did not speak Greek
and so I wonder if you can reflect
on the question of kind of language,
ethnicity and race
and how you use the word
race and racialization.
- Right.
So,
I just find,
particularly for those of us
who
want to be
careful
and want to,
I don't wanna to make a mistake
or don't wanna say the wrong thing
or
that I think sometimes, not always,
but sometimes ethnicity
becomes a code word
or a euphemism when race would
work better, right?
I'm thinking particularly,
I note that
a lot of my colleagues in a broad sense,
fear that if they talk about race
then that makes them racist.
And the two things are
very different, right?
You can talk about race,
that someone is African American,
that doesn't make you racist, right?
So I absolutely agree.
I mean, let's just take Latinx.
Latinx is a linguistic category,
right?
So
folks who are Latinx can be white
or they can be of African descent, right,
or that can be Asian, right?
So yes, there definitely
are linguistic categories.
I have the problem,
the problem I have with,
with Greek is that, Greek, you know,
when we're talking
about the Greeks, right?
It's a little like
the modern day umbrella,
and folks here can correct
me if I get this wrong,
but the modern day umbrella
of Asian,
right?
Oh my goodness.
I mean, that's a huge
category of people, right?
And so you,
you lose the,
the specificity when you
always talk about the Greeks,
but who are you really talking about?
I would say 95% of the time,
you're actually talking
about the Athenians, right?
And so I mean the Spartans
are different, right?
That's, I mean, that's the
most obvious group that,
who is different to the Athenians,
but there were the Lesbians,
there were the Corinthians,
there were the,
all these get lumped in under Greek
and I don't wanna lose that specificity.
I also want us to
really think about
race,
less as something that's physical
and more something that's cultural, right?
And that too is problematic, okay?
Because that opens it up to
all sorts of things like,
oh, so that means Rachel Dolezal is okay
and I'm going, no, no,
no, no, no, no she's not,
no, that's not okay, no, right?
But just to kind of,
what we have to do is we have
to break the stranglehold of,
of the white supremacist,
bio
racism that
developed, right?
That's what I'm trying to do,
trying to break us out of that
and think more broadly
about what race could have been, right,
in antiquity, right,
And it's hard,
I'm not suggesting that
all of this is easy, right?
And yeah, so-
- Shelley, I'm gonna
exercise my prerogative here
as the moderator,
just sort of wonder with you
as a non-classicist in my own field
which is early modern studies.
The early modern studies
and medieval studies have
of course have been roiled
by similar kinds of
conversations about, you know,
how do we talk about race?
And one, one pretty
strong answer coming out
of critical race theory has
been to sort of think about race
as a social category,
as about realities of hierarchization,
about forms of power and
how they are exercised
and to understand them less
as being inscribed on the body
in a biological sense, which is of course,
one way in which race is conceived
in the 19th century, primarily,
but to explore the mechanisms
of social organization
and race as the term that names that.
So for instance, in the
early modern period,
historians have worked on
the term, natial, all right,
and the ideal nation.
How is that in fact a
racialized category perhaps,
not perhaps race in the sense
we might understand it
post 19th and 20th century,
but in a term that
carries that same charge
of social organization
and I wonder if that is helpful
in the classical context as well?
- Yes, I mean I,
just off the top of my
head, I would say, yes.
I think one thing that often gets,
it kind of gets alighted,
is the sense of class.
It's very easy,
I mean all the people, right,
even Medea, for that matter,
even though she's mythical,
ringing in my head is
what my children would say
to me when they were little
and I was sort of struggling
with these things that was going on.
I think it was Dido I
was going on and on about
and both my son and
daughter would say to me,
"Mom, mom, calm down.
They're fictional." (laughing)
So I don't wanna invest
too much in Medea but,
now I forgot what I was gonna say.
Everyone I talked about, right,
is of the ruling class.
Every single one, every single one.
And so when you look at
things like graffiti, right,
the graffiti in Pompeii.
Woohoo, that, hmm, yeah,
what does it mean when someone describes,
you know, that they're
in love with someone and
she happens to be
a black woman.
That's how she described, negra, right?
She's described as a black woman
but the candida women,
which we're not gonna translate as white,
the candida woman is jealous
and gets angry about this.
Well, you know,
we're not talking about
the ruling class now,
where we're talking about
just sort of everyday folks.
So,
I think,
then I think the social probably works.
I think if you get out of the
political class
and you're looking at sort
of everyday kind of folks,
I think
definitely raises a social category
rather than
the status that we have certainly works.
I would say, yeah.
- Shelley, one more question.
Jeff, you should be-
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Professor Haley.
That was a fascinating talk
and it was so wide ranging.
I really enjoyed it
and I hope I have, let's say,
a relevant question.
Thanks to our wonderful post-COVID world,
a lot of us have been taking advantage
of seeing a number of
talks that we might not
otherwise get a chance
to see, including yours.
I heard one last week
which was very interesting
which is the construction of race
in the early Lombard world
and one of the observations,
ethnicity's a better word maybe,
one of her observations,
also similarly focused on the association
of male gender with regards to themselves.
But I was kind of curious
about the rhetorical exercise
of using barbarians,
and I use that,
put that in quotation marks,
to point out the feminine, read weak,
racial stereotypes in themselves
and I was thinking of things
like Tacitus' constructions
of Germanic identity
or Procopius' constructions
of Ostrogothic masculinity
relative to Romans, et cetera.
And I guess my question
really is the degree
to which civilization is perceived
as feminine in these discourses.
- Of course this,
well, let's see.
One way that folks,
this is not me,
this goes beyond me,
but just in terms of
group identity, right?
So group identity formation,
how do you determine what
your group identity is?
And I do think this is trans-historical.
I think this goes across ages.
How do you determine
who your group is, right?
Right?
There's a couple of ways to do that.
You could do the both and, right?
You could say, oh, my
people are other people
who wear headphones
and who are on Zoom.
Those are my people, right?
So it's a series of ands,
it's additive, right?
Or you can do the exclusive, right?
I determine who I am
by checking off what I'm not,
right?
And so I don't know if that's
what you're talking about
but I think you look,
you certainly,
establish the,
I'm gonna to break my own rule,
but the ethnic identity, right,
of the Greeks, right?
Who does he pit them against?
Right?
Does he say it's all the people who
eat olives at lunchtime?
No.
He pits them
against the enemy, right,
who are the Persians,
who do things very different to them.
The same with his
description of the Egyptians.
Oh my God!
The Egyptians like
have sex outdoors, what!
What!
They're barbarians, right?
Or they pee outdoor, whatever,
whatever he says the Egyptians do, right?
So,
yeah, it's
if in the
discourse
of trying to
do, right,
whether you wanna call it racial formation
or group identity formation.
If it's a question of insider, outsider,
then that, you know,
and I think that's the way
most Western societies
have done it, right?
And maybe not just Western.
Certainly any society that
has,
I think about in my own family,
my great grandmother was a member
of the Onondaga Nation, right,
which is part of the Haudenosaunee, right?
So, but when,
when she married outside of the nation,
as she did, right,
and it didn't matter who it was,
it happened to be an African American,
but it didn't matter who it was,
she was no longer a member, right,
of that group.
So that's the way they formed their,
and still do,
their identification.
So,
yeah, I don't know if that
answers your question, Jeff,
but
I think
the outsider, the unknown,
the foreigner is always gonna be portrayed
as the barbarian.
Worth is ethnocentrism
in a nutshell, right?
So we're always superior.
Heavens, we are, right?
We're the best.
American exceptionalism,
we're the best, right?
And that's okay
as long as there isn't value attached,
as long as you don't go out and
shoot people because, right,
they're not American, right?
Americans are only people who
eat apple pie and whatever.
I'm veering off into the silly now.
But, yeah, so I hope that helped.
- One final question.
Tristan, I'm gonna invite you
to unmute yourself in one second.
- It's my friend, Tristan.
- [Ayesha] Go ahead.
- Hi, Tristan, how are you?
- Nice to finally,
which I know the last
questioner brought that up,
beauty of the virtual world.
I finally-
- Yes.
Fantastic, yeah.
Tristan and I go way back. (laughing)
- One of my big influences.
So, but I'll be, try
my best to be concise.
So I have two interconnected questions.
Do you see, 'cause you
know when we have that,
you know, that issue with
the race, ethnicity thing
and I've sort of made the
same observations you have
within, you know, Egyptology
and, you know, study,
you know, in classics.
Do you think also that
there's a relationship
between culture and race or an overlap?
And the second thing
that's intertwined to that,
do you think, keep in mind,
and I use race and racism distinctively,
I make that distinction,
do you think there's
with Roman imperialism
that you can make an argument for racism,
you know, during the Roman Empire
or as a basis of the Roman Empire?
I hope my question makes sense.
And that's my two questions.
- Yeah,
okay.
So let me answer the second one first.
Well, let me ask,
oh, nevermind. (laughing)
I really struggle with this
question about race and culture.
Right?
Is it like chicken and egg or is it?
I think,
what was the number one way,
and whether we're talking about Rome
or whether we're talking about, you know,
ancient Hellenic societies
or we're talking about
modern day, I guess, right?
What's the first thing you
have to do to make a slave?
Right?
But what's the first one you have to do.
Nobody wants to think about this.
You strip them of their culture.
You take them away from their culture.
Right?
So that would make me
think then if that's true
and this was happening before
there was color slavery.
Right, right?
Then there's culture
and then
later at some point, right,
or we can call culture, race, right,
if we're talking about sort of
pre-transatlantic slave trade
or pre-color slavery,
and really I'm getting
out of my wheelhouse here,
so bear with me.
But so you strip someone
of their culture, right,
to dehumanize them,
to,
right,
disassociate them of
what gives them power.
Right?
So in that way,
I mean, I think you could say
they're synonymous, right?
So,
and a part of that is, you know,
not letting them have
their own language, right?
Right?
People that you want to enslave,
you take away their,
the way they express themselves,
you take away their language,
you take away their religion
or the religious practices.
You, right,
you stifle their brains
by not allowing them to be educated.
So,
yeah.
Now that happened, right,
look what the Spartans
did to the Helots, right?
That happened in the ancient,
the ancient Mediterranean
societies, right?
So,
what was the second
question again, Tristan?
I forget.
It was about-
- Racism and Roman imperialism.
- Oh right, yes.
This is a tricky one I think.
This really is a tricky one
because in some ways the
Romans were very clever
in that they didn't,
they didn't strip people
of their language.
They didn't say everybody
has to know Latin
and, you know, force them into schools
like we did the native
Americans and, right?
So they didn't take away the language,
they didn't,
but at the same time,
there was a kind of coerced assimilation.
So,
can we call that racism?
Right?
I guess so.
I mean, I don't,
I don't know
to be honest.
I'd have to think about that one.
I'm down with the imperialism,
I'm down with sort of the,
the ethnocentrism of the Romans.
I'm just not sure whether,
I don't know if it rises to the,
I always use Jim Crow as the, right,
did the Romans pass laws that said
that the Ethiopians, for example,
had to use separate water fountains?
Well, no, they didn't, right?
They didn't.
So,
yeah.
Let me.
- I think this might be a
good time to release Shelley
and thank her very much.
Ayesha and I were just saying
that we'd like to invite,
if this is okay with Professor Haley,
those of you whose questions
didn't get answered,
may they contact you?
- Sure, absolutely.
Absolutely.
- Right.
So your email is on your
Hamilton website, I think.
- Yes and it's very easy.
It's just shaley@hamilton.edu.
- 'Cause I know there were some.
- I see my student, Lexi, from,
hi, Lex! (laughing)
- Hello.
- I know there are some students
from other places as well.
- Right, right.
- So let us thank Professor Haley
and,
well, and say good night.
- Thank you.
- [Ayesha] Thank you so much.